Let's work on forming the /ɹ/ sound.
The sides of your tongue are lightly touching the inside edge of your upper back teeth.
The tongue blade is curled up and reaching just behind the gum ridge,...
...but not touching the teeth.
Your lips might be slightly rounded.
Keep your mouth slightly open and release the voice around the tongue.
Here's the /ɹ/ sound in the beginning of some words.
Right, Reef, Raw.
And here it is in the middle.
Boring, Hurry, Carrot.
Listen to these pairs of words to hear the contrasting sounds.
Role, Dole.
Rot, Lot.
Berry, Belly.
Fearing, Feeling.
Here are some sentences that use the /ɹ/ sound.
Ray will receive a ribbon for running the race.
Great!